[Music]  [Music]  a new world  go now  start over  initiating trimester one  these children are the future of  [Music]  humanity  [Music]  you will raise these children  to be atheists was belief in the unreal  that destroyed the earth  our enemies built an ark which is now  headed here  the only known planet where humans can  survive and should the myth rakes arc  ever make it here  you will not listen to their words they  believe that allowing androids to raise  human children  is a sin  we must rescue our stolen children  do not tell them what i am  i want to talk to you without the  android for a second  she's not a nerd  she's holding him captive he needs to be  with other humans  i thought we were in sync father we've  increasingly taken to  impulses  how many people did you kill on earth  you are all my children  i'm only here to protect you  she's the most powerful weapon on this  planet  i gotta destroy her  what do you want  i want my children to be safe  [Music]  you